hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well from chapter 7
onward in notes from the underground
Fyodor Dostoevsky is going to spell out
for us something that he thinks that
most philosophers and we might even
expand this to all of our life coaches
and psychologists and social reformers
and pick whoever you like there's a
vital aspect of human existence and
value that has been left out and he
calls us the most advantageous advantage
because he's placing this within a
framework within which people have been
talking about interest in advantages and
it explodes the framework as he says it
undoes it it it tears it apart now I
want to say something right from the
start
Dostoevsky here may seem to be
generalizing about human beings across
the board and saying that we're all
driven by this one advantage he's not
actually saying that he is saying that
this is an integral possibility of human
existence that we can never truly rule
out but it's not one that every human
being necessarily is realizing nor do
they have to because it's up to them if
they want to it's up to them if they
want to make it central in their
table of values or hierarchy of needs or
whatever whatever other constructs were
going to use to make sense of this he is
saying that this is something that the
moral philosopher or psychologist or
whoever you're going to be who wants to
understand human nature had better take
account of because it's going to be
there and it's going to be happening
over and over and over again and
exercising its influence
so he's counter posing this to all of
these other people who want to have a
sort of rational empirically based these
days we wouldn't you know talk about
studies and you know constructs and all
of these sorts of things ranging from
you know positive psychology on one end
all the way over through all sorts of
you know neuroscience and and you know
social theory but they all basically
come down to the same fundamental idea
that we could have a a rational and also
empirical or evidence based system that
would harmonize and integrate and
educate people about and over that
process change their interests or
recognition of interests and their
advantages so you know we could get
people to see for example that holding
on to their their superstitions or their
deeply held beliefs might actually be
counterproductive for them if what they
really want is acts and you know why is
interfering with it then maybe why needs
to go even though they're very invested
in why and you know the story of human
progress both intellectually and
socially and in terms of the individual
human person could be understood as a
story about how by application of Reason
by you know integrating other things our
faculties of observation we're able to
fix ourselves make ourselves less
screwed up and you know not just as
individuals but in in relation to each
other as well so
Dostoevsky says that you know what are
the sort of things that they they they
talk about in this improvement of human
beings and society advantages like he
says happiness prosperity freedom
security these are you know we could say
a big big picture buzz words but they
are the things that moral theories and
self-help in psychology and all that you
know social theory really do talk about
a lot why because those are important to
us we do in fact desire happiness we
don't just as our happiness there's
other things we do desire prosperity
however we picture that to ourselves we
do desire freedom we do desire security
and it is possible to get people to
recognize that their picture of
prosperity might in fact be killing
their neighbor or destroying the oceans
or you know doing a whole bunch of other
things that are actually
counterproductive and then then they
could say oh I have to change that you
know I'll stop eating this kind of fish
and eat this kind of fish instead or
we'll have regulations about this or
we'll get rid of regulations or we'll do
this or do that right that's certainly
possible and if it's going to be done
why shouldn't it be evidence-based why
shouldn't it be rational why shouldn't
it be open to public discussion about it
so we arrive at the best way of doing it
now all of this assumes that we can draw
up something like a table or he talked
about it as you know systems or
timetables or you know statistical
averages and scientific formulas and all
sorts of things along those lines and he
says maybe we can come up with a nice
arrangement and ordering of the values
or interests or advantages for human
beings well there's a problem
according to Dostoevsky there's at least
one advantage that has been left out of
the picture why well it's not very
tractable to the sciences it's not very
Staver II for moral philosophy or or
social theory as a matter of fact that
it seems a little selfish it seems a
little self-indulgence but it is to our
advantage she says it is something that
we really do in fact desire not only do
we desire it but it's even something
that is in some respect good for us but
good for us in a way different than all
these other things and Dostoevsky calls
this the most advantageous advantage and
he he says that what's remarkable is
that all of your statists data Titian
stages and humanitarians when listing
human advantages insist on leaving out
one of them they never even allow for it
thus invalidating all their calculations
one would think it would be easy just to
add it to the list but that's where the
trouble lies it doesn't fit into any
scale or chart so you've got two options
exclude it in which case what you're
doing is he's going to call it a little
bit later in one of the chapters to come
it becomes a sterile essentially
abstract academic exercise that doesn't
bear any real connection to to lived
reality that doesn't have any purchased
on it that's not going to effectively
get us to change or you take it into
account and then it's going to explode
your rational system it's going to make
a mess out of it and he brings up his
friend right the composite type who
understands what's good what's beautiful
what's true what's just tells everybody
that he's going to do it and they ought
to follow it and then does the opposite
and starts talking the opposite fifteen
minutes later and he says maybe there's
something that every man values above
the highest individual advantage or so
as not to be illogical there may exist a
human advantage that is the most
advantageous which is also more
important than the others and for the
sake of which a person if need be will
go against reason honor Security and
Prosperity in short against all the
beautiful and useful things just to
attain it the most advantageous
advantage with a lot the one that is
dearest to him and his interlocutor says
oh well you're admitting it's an
advantage yes it is an advantage but
it's not one that fits into your chart
or scale or system
he says the remarkable thing is that it
makes a shamble of all the
classifications and tables drawn up by
humanitarians for the happiness of
mankind it crowds them out as it were
and then that's where he says well these
are all just kind of sterile exercises
in logic so how does he characterize
this advantage he has a number of
different formulas each of which is
worth looking at so that we can get a
full picture of what he has in mind he
says that when we go against the system
as it were says the explanation is so
simple there hardly needs to be any need
for it a person always and everywhere
prefers to act in the way they feel like
acting and not in the way that their
reason and interest tell them for it is
very possible for a person to feel like
acting against their interest and in
some instances I am may say that he
positively wants to act that way but
that's my personal opinion
and then he gives you the formula one's
own free unrestrained choice one's own
whim we're going to come back to that
word in a bit
be it the wildest ones own fancy
sometimes worked up to a frenzy that is
the most advantageous advantage that
cannot be fitted into any table or scale
and causes every system and every theory
to crumble into dust on contact where do
these stage pick up the notion man must
have something they feel as a normal and
virtuous set of wishes all man really
needs is independent will at all costs
and whatever the consequences we want to
will what we want to will and not have
to cram it into some sort of system and
you can think of all the different cases
where this this applies everything from
I don't want to I know that that
following my diet is good for me and I
should exercise tonight but I don't feel
like it I want to do something else
instead I'm gonna go out and have a
couple beers
and then come home and watch some
streaming video and you say well don't
you realize you're setting yourself
behind doing that yeah I know but I want
to do it and this is my life I'm gonna
do it you know people do all sorts of
crazy
apparently stupid things on the basis of
whim when we use that term whim we're
talking about something that doesn't
really have a grounding another word for
this that you know people have used
that's much more morally Laden is is
perversity and you might actually check
out Edgar Allen Poe's essay the IMP of
the perverse which is talking about this
same sort of phenomenon except of course
in a sort of gruesome horror context
less of the day-to-day thing but he
talks about how we can know what we
ought to do and we can say I'm gonna do
something different because I want to do
something different because it's me it's
me I get to decide so he goes on another
passage this is in Chapter 8 he says
that what a person wants to do and why
they go against what what reason
dictates is to establish his right to
wish for the most idiotic things and not
to be obliged to have only sensible
wishes reason would like us to have only
sensible intelligible
publicly-accessible however you want to
frame it right healthy wishes but we
have other wishes and and we have to
decide well do i uproot all those for
myself and become what the picture of
somebody else or or do I accept myself
in you know the fact that I want to do
this I want to sleep in on on Sunday I
want to stay up too late I want to you
know read the book later I want to send
a thank-you note on my own time or
perhaps not at all right he says that
man is actually the most ungrateful
creature
at one point now why why do we want that
and he says well he says it may be more
advantageous to us than all the other
advantages even when it most obviously
harms us and goes against all the
sensible conclusions of our reason about
our interest because whatever else it
leaves us our most important most
treasured possession our individuality
whim and individuality are connected
together notice he doesn't say good
individuality
he doesn't say beautiful individuality
it might be you know I'm this guy and no
this is what I've got you know here's
what I have to offer and it's not great
but it is me and I get to decide for for
me what I'm going to keep so that that's
another way he goes a little further in
chapter 8 and he talks about how harmful
this can be for us at times he says what
can we expect from human beings
considering they're such strange
creatures right they'll risk their cake
for the sake of the most glaring
stupidity for the most economically
unsound nonsense just to inject into all
the soundness and sense surrounding him
some of their own disastrous lethal
fancies what he wants to to preserve is
precisely his noxious fantasies and
vulgar trivialities if only to assure
himself that human beings are still
human beings as if that was so important
says man is somehow averse to the idea
of being unable to desire unless this
desire happens to figure out his
timetable at that moment we want to be
able to hold on to the things that hold
us back from from this other perspective
we want to be able to screw things up I
heard a very interesting statement just
the other day about somebody who went
quite a ways into debt and brought his
wife as well into debt as they were to
discover Lee
and the person who is recalling this to
me and said well actually it makes quite
a bit of sense because I remember him
saying at one time here's my idea if
somebody is dumb enough to sell it to me
well then he'll all buy it and now think
about how stupid that is how irrational
that is you can't regulate a life that
way
can you well yes you can it's just going
to be a bit of a ruin of a life but
nobody said that a life actually has to
be rational
you know evidence-based well arranged or
anything like that and people will
choose sometimes just so that they can
choose for that to be the case in
Chapter 9 he earned a chapter 10 rather
no it is chapter 9 he he brings this to
sort of a close by saying I'm not
advocating suffering any more than well
being human beings can choose suffering
they can choose well-being he says what
I'm for is whim and I want the right to
use it whenever I want to he says I know
for example suffering as in miserable
and utopian light state in in light
stage plays in the Enochian crystal
palace it would be inconceivable but I
don't want the Crystal Palace I don't
want a Crystal Palace that I can't stick
my tongue out at or if we want to use
the equivalent idiom today to give the
finger to I want the right to be able to
decide for myself even if what I'm
deciding for is actually quite stupid
and irrational and goes against the
evidence because that is valuable to me
that is the most advantageous advantage
and you can see how once you admit this
into the picture it undoes any sort of
chart or timetable that you put together
they're all rather contingent they don't
represent a rational necessity that we
all have to follow if we do happen to
follow them that's actually luck or our
desires coming together or reason
managing to thread the needle
of convincing people to actually behave
rationally a good portion of the time so
this is what
Dostoevsky thinks everybody who's going
to talk about human beings either has to
take into account or they're engaging in
a kind of abstract logic exercise
you